[Music]
on this friday night payne in the gas
canadians contend with record high
prices at the pumps it's just awful i
can't even believe it what's fueling the
increase and can drivers expect any
relief down the road more evidence of
war crimes committed by russian forces
in ukraine and fresh fears for what lies
ahead as russia prepares to mark victory
day a powerful explosion destroys a
five-star havana hotel
the chaos casualties and suspected cause
manitoba's farmers flooded the disaster
and devastating consequences plus 23rd
times a charm we're thrilled but not
surprised the latest twist in this
canadian jeopardy champions record run
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us canadian drivers had a crude
awakening this morning gas prices across
the country climbed to record highs
nearing or even exceeding the two dollar
benchmark
vancouver residents are paying among the
most at around 2.17 cents per liter the
lowest prices are in alberta but even
they are paying above a dollar sixty
today heading east torontonians are
shelling out around a dollar 95 per
liter gas is above two dollars in
montreal while in atlanta canada drivers
are paying slightly less but still a
record of around 1.91
that growing gas bill comes as many
canadians are already struggling to cope
with the rising cost of living as
abigail beamon reports there's little
relief in sight
130 dollars and 33 cents have you ever
had to pay that much
never ever well in a boat yes but in a
vehicle like i know
i don't drive a transport truck or
anything
with gas nearing or exceeding the two
dollar a liter mark in places across the
country many motorists feel handcuffed
you're kind of gouged in the sense that
hey we all got to go to work i'm only
putting in 30 dollars
yeah i'm just gonna top it up a little
bit
maybe ride it out see what my budget can
do
if they can't cut back on driving some
are forced to make other changes it's
hard and you know i'm a single mom so i
don't make a double salary so i've got
to make cuts where
where i can ten says people think it's
not it's nothing but 10 cents it's
something
according to statistics canada this is
how gas prices have climbed across the
country since last may when prices
averaged a dollar thirty one and a half
per liter to march 2022
people in the bc lower mainland
consistently pay the most for gas while
those in edmonton pay the least
driving daily life difficulty wage
stagnation and small pay increases that
come nowhere near the overall climbing
inflation rate those gas prices are
going to work their way uh through the
supply chain right so those vegetables
that you're buying at the store or meat
that you're buying at the store
all of them will be affected for those
who are struggling which tends to be a
lot of middle class and poor canadians
uh the fact that uh you know
alternatives are not scalable they're
not reliable or not affordable
i think really puts us in a bit of a
bind a complex bind that analysts say
doesn't have a quick solution
unfortunately continue to set new
records almost every day
as we make the transition to summer
gasoline across canada and as we see oil
prices continue to go up as a result of
the russian invasion of ukraine
more canadians than ever are now
deciding whether it's worth hitting the
road but many still can't afford not to
abigail beeman global news ottawa
and one factor driving those gas prices
to record highs is the war in ukraine
where today we saw a sliver of good news
a humanitarian convoy carrying 50 women
children and elderly people made it
safely out of that marijuana steel plant
a desperate relief for the dozens now
out of that besieged port city but many
more remain trapped inside and as
redmond shannon reports the window to
rescue them may be about to close
the hint of a smile after two months in
hellish conditions
buses that made their way out of azov
style steel plant friday stopped off for
the night in a village just outside
mariupol
ukraine's azov battalion says one of its
soldiers was killed early friday when
russian forces fired at the evacuation
convoy it's not known how many civilians
remain inside as of style perhaps over a
hundred
along with ukrainian troops their fate
for better or worse could be decided by
monday
that's the victory day public holiday in
russia when it's expected vladimir putin
will want something to celebrate the
fighting in ukraine but especially in
mariopol has been turned into this
almost a mini small scale symbolic
victory so mariopol is very important
amnesty international now says it has
gathered evidence that russian troops
committed war crimes in the region north
of kiev we know they are part of a
pattern
that has characterized
russia's conduct of the hostilities from
the outset
a repeated pattern
large in scale and devastating in impact
russia has denied targeting civilians on
friday its u.n ambassador called such
evidence a coordinated campaign of lies
the reality however is strong strikingly
different
and ukrainian authorities in the western
bankers are not interested in shedding
any light on it of course russia has
also denied this is a war at all
the kremlin is also lashing out at those
who suggested russia might use nuclear
weapons
but twice in recent weeks russian state
tv aired segments describing potential
nuclear attacks against the west
and as victory day approaches one of the
aircraft practicing flypasts above
moscow is the illusion il-80 russia's
airborne command center for a would-be
nuclear war redmond shannon global news
london in cuba rescuers are combing
through mounds of rubble tonight after
an explosion at a luxury hotel in havana
killed at least 18 people including a
pregnant woman and a child while
officials say no visitors were staying
at the popular tourist destination at
the time dozens have been injured and
many more are still missing jackson
proskow reports on the suspected cause
of the explosion
these appear to be the moments after the
explosion at havana's landmark hotel
saratoga
moments later a frantic search through
the rubble for survivors in the city's
old quarter
it was a blast that threw me said this
witness
the explosion ripped the facade off the
historic building exposing the first
three stories of rooms to the street
below
vehicles in the street were destroyed
thick smoke filled the area as rescuers
rushed to help the injured
hotel
cuban state tv showed ambulances on the
scene and paramedics helping move the
wounded to hospital
the hotel is directly across the street
from cuba's national capitol building
speaking from outside a hospital cuban
president miguel diaz-canel was quick to
rule out a terrorist attack or bombing
the hotel was apparently undergoing
final preparations for a post-pandemic
reopening and was not occupied by guests
at the time of the blast the state-run
hotel operator said workers were
resupplying gas to the building when the
explosion took place
this is what the hotel saratoga looked
like before the explosion a stunning art
deco relic of the 1930s
now just a heaping pile of rubble in the
heart of havana
jackson proskow global news
in southern manitoba are used to dealing
with some spring flooding but nothing
like this
take a look at these communities under
water boats are now needed to get around
morris that's about 75 kilometers
southwest of winnipeg and other regions
are dealing with much of the same there
are concerns about the overall damage to
the agriculture industry farmers expect
to lose millions of dollars abigail
turner has more on when the flood waters
will recede
so there's about
i would say about three four feet of
water on the bridge
one year after a record-setting drought
in manitoba and farmers in the red river
valley are now faced with this well the
problem with flooding is
we just don't know how bad it's going to
get
ray shaw has lived in morris a southern
manitoba town of about 1200 for 20 years
the only way he can get to his front
step is by boat he has a permanent dike
built around his yard to protect 50
sheep we knew enough when the roads were
lower to bring in feed bring in this
bring in all the stuff i have sand bags
here if all of a sudden there is a two
inch rain
the flooding is so widespread it's
beginning to change local weather
patterns on the downwind side we get the
development of clouds and that can
sometimes bubble up to be like effect
snow in the winter some rain in the
summer but thankfully there's not enough
moisture to trigger that the overland
flooding spans 30 kilometers at its
widest point that's half the size of
winnipeg and the depth of all that water
could spell doom for some farmers
there's six feet of water on the fields
that we can do thorsten stance has been
growing grain and oil seed here for 40
years of his 6 000 acres 50 000 are
under water our optimum window is the
first second week in may
if you have to see the first or the
second week in june
you can expect a year decrease of i
don't know 30 percent and that has
devastating financial impacts there's
some potential for a thousand dollars an
acre of what we would consider revenue
when you take that times 10 million
acres
the numbers are huge
for now farmers like shaw have their
eyes glued to the skies there's the
potential for more rain this weekend
with the crest of the red river valley
that's anticipated next week it can't
come soon enough abigail turner global
news winnipeg
and to flooding south of the border now
where more than 25 million americans are
in the path of severe thunderstorms
a line of storms was tearing across
portions of the south and the midwest
the system spawned several tornadoes in
texas and oklahoma yesterday officials
there say several homes and dozens of
businesses were destroyed roadways are
underwater with wind speeds forecast to
reach over 110 kilometers per hour
out of office
coming up how canadians are feeling
about returning to the workplace
plus royally snubbed we'll tell you who
is being excluded from a key event
marking the queen's jubilee
[Music]
there's some good news for canada's
economy today new data shows the jobless
rate has fallen again to another record
low according to statistics canada the
unemployment rate for april came in at
5.2 percent that's down from the
previous record of 5.3 set in march the
jobless rate has been falling steadily
since reaching an all-time high two
years ago at the height of the pandemic
that labor market is tightening at the
same time as many businesses are making
plans to bring employees back to the
office but workers in high demand can
hold more influence over where and how
they want to work zan gaviola reports
canadians appear divided about the
changes in store
you could call it the great divide when
it comes to the future of work going
back into the office you really get that
you know opportunity to see people in
real life again
so you can have some of those quick
conversations that i couldn't have
otherwise i really like the productivity
and the flexibility that working from
home gives me ipsos polling exclusively
for global news suggests people who have
worked remotely during the pandemic are
split on the return to the office but
united in embracing flexible schedules
many canadians want the changes that the
pandemic brought to the workplace to be
permanent and for things to not go back
the way they were
before that fateful day in march 2020.
in fact one in three say they'd look for
another job if their employer forced
them to work exclusively at the office
and yet 42 percent say they're happiest
at their place of work rather than
working from home the divide is
especially pronounced among younger
workers nearly half of people between
the ages of 18 and 34 say they prefer to
be in the office rather than working
remotely now that may reflect a desire
for many to learn and connect with
colleagues from those starting out in
their careers but a little more than
half of young workers say they just want
to work from home working remotely or in
the workplace is very much linked to the
housing crisis that we're seeing right
now young people are are struggling to
save up for down payments the average
savings for remote workers in 2021 was
about two hundred dollars a week or more
than eleven hundred dollars a year
according to cisco canada that's money
saved on commuting lunches out child
care pet care and work attire with a
rapidly rising cost of everything those
numbers are only going up
attitudes on where and how to work have
shifted with 44 saying their workplace
now offers flexible arrangements that
didn't exist pre-pandemic
hybrid schedules are the most common in
ontario where more than half say their
workplace has adopted a flexible model
followed by atlantic canada and bc at 43
percent and quebec 38
time will tell whether changes ushered
in during the pandemic will fade away or
give way to a new normal in and out of
the workplace ann gaviola global news
toronto
mysteries of the metaverse still ahead
what's driving investors to this virtual
frontier
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
there we can see the deployment of those
main parachutes
less than 24 hours after the spacex crew
3 mission left the international space
station the capsule splashed down in the
gulf of mexico three nasa astronauts and
one from the european space agency spent
six months on board the iss testing new
technologies from growing crops and
printing bandages made from skin cells
directly onto the wound spacex founded
by the world's richest man elon musk has
helped launch 26 people into space over
the past couple of years
mark zuckerberg calls it living in the
future the metaverse aims to be a
virtual universe where users from around
the world can interact in immersive
digital spaces it's still being
developed and is a little rough around
the edges but that hasn't stopped tech
giants brands and even everyday people
from rushing to build and invest kayla
mclean has been working on this story
for the new reality
kayla in what's being described as the
next evolution of the internet the race
is on to develop the virtual world of
the future some investing thousands and
even millions into real estate and one
of them is a diner owner from montreal
david minikucci has only been the owner
of the famous cosmos for less than two
years but he's been going to the
montreal diner since he was a teenager
he decided to buy the restaurant because
it holds a lot of sentimental value for
him david wanted to expand the brand but
not with another bricks and mortar
location
instead david spent close to fifteen
thousand dollars to buy land in the
metaverse and open a virtual cosmos you
know i'm an entrepreneur i i want to you
know grow the business just like anybody
else would want to do but at the same
time i truly have an emotional
attachment to this place and i'll never
change what we actually do here
david is just one of many people whether
investors or tech giants racing to own a
piece of virtual land and investing in
the future of the metaverse it's
expected to be a multi-trillion dollar
revenue opportunity
there are a handful of online platforms
that offer metaverse experiences
some owned by companies and others that
are community driven for example
decentraland sandbox and horizon worlds
rn mani also known as mr who's the boss
is a youtube tech expert based in the uk
so i like to define it as it's not an
internet that you're looking at through
a screen it's an internet that you're
inside of one of the coolest things in
the metaverse is this idea of being able
to feel close to people who are further
away
so
imagine a world where we're perfectly
connected you can almost snap your
fingers and feel like you're in the same
room as someone who's on a different
continent and you'll be able to kind of
see everything from their facial
expressions to their like emotions
through their virtual avatar that's
that's kind of the promise of the
metaverse now with all the potential and
buzz around the metaverse there are some
real life concerns will the problems
currently plaguing social media transfer
to these communities and platforms and
also will your data and privacy be
protected
jeff
caleb mclean in toronto thanks kayla
and kayla will have more about the
metaverse's potential and concerns over
data and privacy that's on the new
reality tomorrow night at 8 o'clock
right here on global
25 roach's record run next can canada's
greatest jeopardy chant keep her winning
streak alive
[Music]
welcome back buckingham palace is
preparing to celebrate the queen's
platinum jubilee next month which will
include the standard royal photo op from
the balcony but this time princess harry
and andrew are not invited
the palace says only working members of
the royal family will join the queen on
the iconic balcony during opening
celebrations on june the 2nd prince
harry and wife megan gave up royal
duties in 2020 but they're still
planning to travel to the uk to mark the
queen's 70 years on the throne prince
andrew meanwhile relinquished royal
duties following a now settled sexual
assault case but he will also attend
other events to some breaking news now
and a major spoiler alert for anyone who
hasn't watched tonight's episode of
jeopardy after 23 straight wins canadian
contestant matteo roach's record run has
ended
it has been a pleasure watching you play
the game
the nova scotia-born roach lost by just
one dollar in tonight's final round but
her defeat is bittersweet she won more
than half a million u.s dollars making
her the winningest canadian ever as ross
lord reports maritimers say she's a
marvel
matia what is cloak and dagger you got
it secret word two
matea roach has shown more knowledge
about more things than almost anyone
who's ever played jeopardy what is the
golden gate bridge yeah she's got
emotional intelligence to spare too
she's humble like this mid-game shout
out to the debate coach at her high
school in halifax brian casey he would
come up to me my partner and be like
okay girls it's show time so that's what
i was thinking last week every time
before i came up to play so i wanted to
thank him oh well i was crying of course
i i had no expectation that there was
going to be anything like that happening
we're thrilled but not surprised by her
success she's wicked smart you would
never think that someone from a school
so local that your own school would
actually make it on such a big stage in
such an international stage like
jeopardy matea has always stood out in
this era of continuous distraction she
pays attention and recalls information
instantly her family home is among many
in nova scotia where people gather to
see or compete providing excitement to
offset the drudgery of the pandemic and
other distressing events people are you
know wonderfully supportive and
it's it's a real satisfying thing to see
that that response to uh to your kid
her father says matea does have a
cutting sense of humor she hasn't shown
off on tv and she has the same neck as
all great competitors for making the
right move at the right time last night
was really scary is a nail fighter
but we were all so happy every night
when she wins she was in second place
with thirteen thousand dollars what film
did you write down what is citizen kane
if this is it thanks for the fun it is
citizen king her front-running opponent
had nothing and at just 23 years old a
23-day total of 560
hundred and eighty three dollars after
piling up more than seven hundred
thousand dollars canadian in winnings
it's as safe that mateo will integrate
her success into her future with
intelligence and with charm
ross lord global news halifax
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm jeff semple tonight's
your canada is stafford lake in the city
of brooks alberta we love seeing your
canada so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you